welcome to this video five-minute chest
armor gr from the US killing for this
interesting sideline it's a one of the
better sight lines against brilliant the
screen fold on King zillion type of
setups mmm I could also check with the
bishop go with ya this is this is
developing a piece let's do that okay
maybe queen bee three intending 95 well
i got the bishops if you know my channel
are you know mine bishop pair fetish i
always want to have them okay so what is
the idea of night you form
hmm 926 maybe yeah possible all right a
complete development
maybe d5 is some here threatening d5 you
cannot play a 6 e 6 I can just take and
now maybe maybe g5s irritating or b-five
hmm
hmm
maybe 95 as an idea this has got the
idea of flank v6 this one one
possibility and also f3 simply trapping
the night f 395 ad this this is the
night or not 95 h4 and it's gone it was
a bit tricky anyway but this just gives
me this piece I think
was one of the ideas it rocked the ADA
sunshine was we're here I can take it
the lab resigns yeah just a frustration
move you know but blackest black is
already in bed in bad shape yeah white
is winning anyway the comp says yeah I
wasn't so sure about that i thought what
is certainly better but winning is
another matter but gathers really no
move i also have bishop deform as a
additional idea yeah but he cannot
cannot help his his night this f3 threat
is deadly this means that probably hear
you have been 95 then wins it's very
clear have some tanks and this means
that queen bee success probably the
losing booth 96 is what he needs to do
but okay it's just those two and ideas
to play against the pole on c6 with the
Queen on c7 yeah why does better him but
not winning the the way it played out it
was said was a direct win thanks for
watching